Understanding objects, fields, and records is important to conceptualize
the data model that you're building in the music
festival app. Let's make sure you understand what's going
on. So, let's pretend that you're Amazon.com, and you
want to keep track of the inventory at a
warehouse. Your warehouse stocks lots of things, books, movies,
clothing, et cetera. But you refer to the individual
things as an item. Each item has some properties
like a name, a price, and a weight. For
example, a Udacity t-shirt costs $15 and weighs six
ounces. If you were to represent this in Sales
Force, what would each of these capitalized terms correspond to?